so my friend was seeing this Matchmaker  for himself and he was like I'm seeing  this Matchmaker you should see them too  and I was like all right I'll give it a  try because I hadn't really tried the  apps I talked with her on the phone and  then she did set me up on a date but  then I didn't know her  her CV as they say her don't tell me it  was the millionaire matchmaking no yeah  I didn't know I didn't know Daddy was  saying her I love Patty's Day do you  guys watch Patty Stinger's show I used  to watch all the time but ironically I I  kept saying to her like I've never dated  anyone with a lot of money I've really  dated people that are funny and  interesting and artists but I just was  like I'm not looking for someone  fabulous or rich or I don't know I just  I don't know if if if we're a match  Patty yeah you don't need a Millionaire  Matchmaker you need like a hilarious  Matchmaker